bon alors il ya du théâtre ce soir dans
là où ça bouge puisque c'est le je suis
en plus que ccp broc théâtre alors
j'avais noté on sent bien les petites
lattes de bois s'incruster dans les
faits sont elles doivent être trop fine
on trouve écartée
enfin bon c'est c'est évident que le gac
a construit ce bon là s'est jamais assis
dessus
il a scellé dans le square et basta
c'est quoi le square marc frémont c'est
la nouveauté c'est la nouvelle pièce du
paigc rock ça sort bientôt là c'est un
texte vous avez écrit oui c'est s'est
construit à base de textes courts qui se
passe en fait dans un square quoi il ya
deux personnages sur scène voilà il ya
celui que j'interprète qui n'a pas de
nom et celui qui interprète patrick
raffaud qui n'a pas non plus on est de
deux collègues de square un peu on s'est
rencontrés sdf dans ce square là il ya
longtemps
il ya un côté beckett ou pas il ya un
côté beckett ou pas sous couvert de
bouffonnerie un peu à la méthode du
bouffon du roi qui ont lu passer bien
des choses parce qu'il avait l'air
cinglé donc cette folie permet de dire
des choses plus dérangeante sans être
sans être méchant quoi là me traversent
eux sa vie dans les clous avec ses
congénères brillant galvaniser un peu 4
pouces ensemble avec avec la peur la
peur du marteau au ventre la peur qui
tenaille qui arrachent les tripes
marteau qui est pas trop laid trop il
ferraille et peur de la rouille et l'âme
s'entassent avec ses congénères dans les
boîtes à clos à l'abri de l'humidité et
il a une vie deux clous un écouter la
parole écrite par marc frémont c'est
donc mardi
donc on est mardi donc c'est ce soir et
demain c'est exactement au théâtre des
cordes c'est à 20h30
oui et un numéro de résa si on va sur le
pembroke théâtre
voilà un petit peu de jazz avec l'organe
trio gaël horellou frédéric nardin et
antoine paganotti seront deux mains au
côté cour du théâtre de caen à 21h
lem ça bouge nous sommes à l'aigle salle
verdun pour voir la femme comme champ de
bataille enfin là tout de suite c'est la
répétition on les laisse travailler
ils étaient cinq je ne sais pas s'ils
étaient musulmans croient tous serbe
vous savez en bosnie enfin tous le serbo
croate il faut que je parte maintenant
il faut noter dans votre rapport que je
ne sais pas s'ils étaient musulmans
croates serbes au revoir doha je joue le
rôle de doha une jeune femme bosniaque
qui a été violée pendant la guerre des
balkans
vous voulez que je vous raconte comment
ils m'ont violée
no je ne veux pas que tu me racontes
quoi que ce soit je joue le rôle de kate
qui est une américaine et elle elle se
met comme psychologue dans un hôpital
pour aider des femmes qui ont été
violées
il n'y a pas non plus que le violent
d'un il ya aussi lui ce conflit
dièye a pas si longtemps qui est pas si
loin de la france est en fait je me suis
dit mais si je l' ai vu aux infos mais j
y ai des choses que je n'ai pas bien
compris et non le fait de me replonger
là-dedans effectivement voilà ça c'est
difficile oui oui ça concerne tout le
monde même si effectivement la première
victime fin là c'est une femme
d'où l'importance d'avoir pris un coup
au metteur en scène avec moi un homme
parce que justement voulais pas que ça
soit une pièce féminine ou féministes
voilà de l'élargir quand on lit que des
hommes pendant la guerre des balkans
étaient obligés de violer leur fille
voir leur mère je crois que si les
victimes ce sont des sommes assez
partagé le propos dépasse de loin
la dénonciation du viol des femmes c'est
beaucoup plus vaste qui kiffent état de
des conflits actuels et nouveaux types
de conflits dans lesquels on entrait
depuis quelques décennies déjà
la répétition publique de la femme comme
champ de bataille c'est demain 18h30
salle de verdun à l'aigle et la
représentation le 12 mai au quai des
arts
argent tu vaux fait quand vous voulez
c'est la nouvelle du jour le grand
retour de michel polnareff une grande
tournée française un nouvel album et un
passage au festival des papillons de
nuit de saint laurent de pub ce sera le
dimanche 22 mai promis qu'il chantera
aussi ses vieux standards at mall toutes
les brebis et tous les bandits
on ira tous au d